le portique au dessus des voies a vécu
débarrasser des caténaires qu'il
soutenait il a dû être enlevés pour
permettre la destruction des quais on
est en train de se mettre dans les
conditions pour démarrer tous les
travaux de génie civil donc la première
parcours consiste à la dépose des
poteaux caténaires se trouve aux droits
de la création des rampes d'accès aux
souterrains qui permettra de relier
souterrain et quai pour les usagers à la
place des caisses des tranchées de
quatre mètres de profondeur vont être
creusés pour laisser place à une rampe
d'accès en pente douce de 46 mètres de
long 4 mètres c'est la profondeur
nécessaire à l'installation des
ascenseurs l'ascenseur et sa réponse est
à la fin de l'année et ils seront un
service en janvier 2021 pour que 4 et 5
et fin d'année 2021 pendant les travaux
le passage souterrain est inaccessible
du côté de l'avenue albert 1er fermée à
la circulation
les études de projet lancé il ya dix ans
au prix du retard relancée il ya quatre
ans la mise en accessibilité de la gare
de dijon est très attendu super mais je
dirais enfin voilà parce que je jouais
rappeler la loi de 2005 qui disait que
en 2015 100 % des erp établissements
recevant du public serait accessible et
on est en 2021 ouvriers des travaux
commencent ça a été des ouvertures de
droits à 3 6 9 ans pour pour être
accessible pour nous c'est trop long les
travaux vont durer huit semaines
jusqu'au 30 août